Clint: Dude that move, that move
Gui: There's been times where I've been to the verge of tears
Niko: It's actually giving me a headache trying to watch this and like analyze it
Clint: This is all i'm seeing
[Laughter]
Niko: Hey guys, welcome back to another episode of Stuntmen React
Niko: We're happy to be able to finally film with guests again and Gui has graciously come in
Niko:  Gui is a legend, he's done some incredible things
Niko: He's going to give you that professional insight into one of the most unique and coolest jobs that you could ever possibly have
Clint: So yeah, we're gonna hop into some clips here
Clint: Let's get started with one of my favorite Kung fu movies of all time
Clint: Kung Fu Hustle is directed by one of my all-time favorite directors
Clint:  I could go on for hours about how much I love Stephen Chow
Gui: I love his versatility
Clint: Same
Gui: Definitely one of my favorite directors of all time
Clint: He is a genius
[Yelling]
Clint: So good
Gui: So he's in... he's on a Hong Kong harness
Gui: Which only... it's like a belt and it goes through... it's similar to what climbing harness looks like
Clint: Okay
Gui: He's picked at the hips, so that when he jumps
Gui: They... they time it with him and doesn't lift up his shirt or anything like that
Gui: What I really like about the Hong Kong harness is the fact that it allows
Gui: Your athleticism to be part of the performance rather than you just going for the ride
Clint: Yeah
Gui: In a sense, which they need him to do at this moment because he has to
Gui: Be in rhythm with them and bounce and jump at the same time and throw the kicks and land
Gui: And have that weight on top of it
Niko: Kicks them so hard dust comes off of them
Niko: They need to wash their clothes some more
Clint: Wait a second
Clint: How'd they get that dust puff, on that face kick right here?
Clint:  Look at this
Gui: Yeah
Clint: Did he throw it with his hand?
Gui: No
Gui: It's on his foot
Niko: It just flicks off his toe
Niko: Also in a little bit later you can see there's a part where he just slides his foot through a pile to kick it up into the air, also
Niko: Gui, what do you use for that dust?
Gui: I mean usually you use baby powder, but there is another kind of dust that's a little bit thicker, that we use
Niko: You just slam his head on the ground
Niko: Nope
Gui: No, he didn't he saved himself
Clint: That was a shoulder or something
Gui: That was great
Gui: That was actually a really good reaction
Clint: He got caught
Gui: Pow! look he used his arm to save himself
Clint: He was like, "Boom!"
Gui: Just enough
Gui: Just... just... just enough
Clint: Dude that enough got launched
Clint: Look at this guy... roller coaster ride
Niko: That's so rad such a sick reveal
Gui: well this part's cg, right
Clint: That's real
Gui: This is real and then he goes
[Metal clinking]
Gui: Absolutely VFX
Gui: And then this is just glued together
Gui: I believe it's Hung Ga
Gui: It's a northern style, so it's very deep stances
Gui: The style tiger that you see in kung fu films for the most part is of that origin
Gui: Which also will explain why a lot of the...
Gui: Martial arts movements of this style is it's always so big and round
Gui: Because they're actually hitting with their forearms more than their fists at times
Clint: Dude that move
Gui: Yeah, that double the jump split back kicks
Clint: He does a really good job of making impossible moves look possible
Gui: Right, He's very anime inspired
Clint: Yeah
Gui: That's what I really liked about Kung Fu Hustle and resonated with me
Gui: Was his ability to take ideas from animation and put it into live action
Clint: Dude, 100%
Clint: He is the best director who's done anime to live action style
Gui: Yes
Clint: Um, like Shaolin Soccer
Clint: Dude
Gui: Right
Gui: Just doing it non-stop and everybody's just running out
Gui: "Ahhh... We're going to get hit... Ahhh..."
Niko: Dude aim for the top hats
[Laughter]
Gui: So much style, so much, like, that... that soul that's in it makes it even more fun to watch
Niko: He's got the craziness in his eyes
Niko: He's got that desperate... yeah
Niko: He stomps with his foot when he hits at the same time and he holds it and everything just shakes because there's so much force behind it
Clint: Yeah
Niko: And like his chest is back, you know, it's like [Grunts]
Gui: Oh, man
[Grunts]
Clint: Yeah
Clint: It's so sick
Gui: It's so important
[Fly buzzing]
[Smack]
Gui: Oh you.... mot-
Niko: If anybody catches a fly on screen by the way
Gui: I'm gonna... I'm ummm...
Gui: By the end of this episode that that fly is mine
Clint: Hey, we love hearing from you guys
Clint: What's your favorite martial arts movie, in fact, what's your favorite martial arts scene?
Clint: Leave a comment down below
Clint: We love taking a look
Clint: We'll break it down on the show right here
Gui: There's... there's been times on this show, where I've doubled, uh, Turk, where I've been to the verge of tears
Clint: Whoah
Gui: Because of how... how... how much it hurts working nights, in New York City, during the fall winter is not fun
Clint: Okay
Gui: So, there's a fall here that I wasn't a fan of
Clint: Ooh...
Gui: So it's New York City, it's 2 a.m
Gui: Close to 15 degrees outside and it's about 10 feet... 15 feet
Gui: They are like, "He's... you're gonna you're gonna hit and splat"
Gui: I'm like, "Cool. This is gonna be great"
Gui: "We're gonna put a little neoprene mat for you"
Gui: And neoprene's like this thick, you know
Gui: That neoprene was actually harder than the roof
Niko: Really?
Clint: What?
Gui: Because when it's cold it stiffens up even more
Gui: I did that maybe seven times
Gui: I might as well should have just been landing on the ground without it
Gui: Because it's not only just the impact, but then it's the freezing burn that comes after it
Gui: Of your palms getting... scraping across your... your chest, get smacking
Gui: And that wasn't fun, at all
Clint: Here's my thing though
Gui: Hmm?
Clint: In the edit.... Well, you don't see the full thing
Gui: Right, there's more to the chase than what they actually showed
Gui: And they... they cut a good chunk of it out
Gui: So i'm supposed to land on it... on a lower ledge, then jump to the stairs that you see over there
Gui: And then i'm supposed to run and instead of go down the last flight i'm supposed to just jump
Gui: And just try to make it, and that's what we do, but you know, you don't see it in the shot
Gui: It just looks like I fell from on top of the ledge
Gui: So again, you do a whole bunch of work and at times you're only going to get a third of it shown, you know, in the edit
Gui: Charlie Cox is really cool though
Gui: We were doing squats to stay warm
Gui: He does squats before every scene, like, before they start action
Gui: He... he pumps his heart up, he just gets it going
Clint: Every... like no matter it's cold, no matter it's hot... everything?
Gui: Yep
Gui: I'm gonna tell him he should come on here
Niko: Yeah?
Gui: And then you guys should do an actor's react
Niko: You think he would do that?
Gui: I don't see why not
[Phone chimes]
Niko: Wait, hold on... hold on... hold on
Niko: Charlie Cox just called me and he said, "Niko i'm not going to go on your show"
Niko: "Until Corridor Crew gets 4 million subscribers"
Niko: I'm like you know what, Charlie Cox? We're at 3.91
Gui: Whoah
Niko: So we just need 90 000 subscribers
Gui: Come on
Niko: That's right guys
Niko: Help us get Charlie Cox on the show, right now
[Fly buzzing]
[Smack]
Gui: Hey
Gui: Did you get it?
[Gasping]
Gui: You got it
Oh my god
Clint: Okay, close up
Gui: Get it
[Fly buzzes off]
Everyone: Whoah!
Gui: You got duked
[Laughter]
Niko: Clint punches like a pansy
Clint: It's health bar is like down a little bit now
Gui: It's half now
Clint: Yeah
Gui: It's moving a little slower now
Niko: So Game of Thrones has some great sword fights and has some not great sword fights
[Laughter]
Niko: I remember being pretty disappointed with this fight scene
Clint: "Whoah"
[Grunts]
[Laughter]
Gui: Oh god
Niko: These shots aren't really even showing any beat in particular, like, there you go, okay
Niko: You show the block and then you show the swing and then... woohoo
Gui: Like... what? Now his sword is all ready... and he's going for a thrust
Gui: So I feel like they double cut that
Gui: So that strike that we see... that overhand it
Gui: The close-up that follows afterwards is actually for that strike
Niko: Yeah, I agree 100%, that's just... that's the same move right there, play it again
[Record scratch]
Clint: What was that?
[Laughter]
Niko: She goes...
[Grunts]
Niko: And then she-
Clint: Runs away
Niko: Runs away
[Laughter]
Niko: "Just kidding, I'm back in the fight"
Niko: Oh she won, she's bested him somehow
Gui: No
Clint: How? I like literally... how?
Clint: Hold on... hold on... hold on...
[Laughter]
Gui: She kicked him in the back of the knee
Clint: Like, actually, what happened... like really what happened?
Gui: Spin moved and then she kicked him
Niko: She kicked him in the... face
Clint: This is all i'm seeing
Clint: Like
Gui: I feel like
Clint: That's all I'm seeing
Gui: She did that move once and they made it look like she did it twice
Niko: Yeah
Clint: Okay, that's probably what it was, and then somehow he's down
Clint: I still don't know how he's down
Gui: Right here
Gui: It's right... kick
Clint: Dude... blink
[Laughter]
Gui: Kick
[Grunts]
Clint: In the most like-
Niko: And then it cuts to her on the impact for some reason
Clint: The most backwards, like, far away angle for a kick
Niko: Also the hound is like the toughest motherf****** in Westeros
Niko: He gets bonked in the chin with her toe and now he's down
Niko: Yeah, it's actually it's like it's actually giving me a headache trying to watch this and like analyze it
Gui: I'm trying to follow it
Niko: Like, it's cut so roughly and like yeah, just none of the angles flow like they're forcing
Niko: They're forcing it really hard
Clint: Yeah, like I can't breathe watching this
[Pained yelling]
Clint: Yeah, this is better than the Sword fight
Gui: Yeah
Clint: But it's still it's getting a little... oof... getting a little
Gui: Oh, now we're jumping
Niko: It feels like a camera crew was just told to get a couple angles of a fight scene
Niko: So they did and then there's just no cohesion
Clint: You think they were just out there?
Clint: They're like, "all right, we gotta film all this stuff"
Clint: "You guys just just film this section, just film the fight scene"
Niko: I kind of feel... I don't know man
Niko: Like it was really... this is a big build-up and I think it was just a case of like, you know
Niko: Both the actors wanted to do the scene themselves
Niko: Some people just don't quite have it yet for sword fighting, you know
Niko: When they did the Matrix, you know, Keanu Reeves and Laurence Fishburne
Niko: They all had to train for like months and months and months, and I feel like this is like a couple weeks
Gui: And it's also TV
Niko: It's also TV
Gui: There's been good fights on this show
Gui: The Battle of the Bastards
Gui: That was very well done
Niko: It was an amazing fight scene
Gui: And
Niko: The trial by combat
Niko: Oh, that's a good fight scene
Gui: Liang is dope, the same dude choreographed and doubled, uh, for that fight scene
Gui: He is in Mission Impossible Fallout, he fought Henry Cavill and-
Gui: Yeah, so... they've captured stuff way better than that
Niko: Let's just say they didn't have a lot of time on set
Niko: You know, I would I would ascertain they maybe had a day or two to shoot this entire scene
Niko: Gui?
Gui: Yes?
Niko: What would you do to make the scene better?
Gui: I would get the shots that you need with your actors, your big points, and then I would use the wides that they have
Gui: Where they're using the stunt performers and let that be the... the brandishing of the fight choreography and then cut in for the more visceral
Gui: Intimate scenes that come on later on, but then it's up to the editor to make that come to fruition
Gui: And I don't think it happened here
Gui: And I get what they're trying to do because these are two very important characters to the story
Gui: And they want to show them both being powerful
Gui: But they're trying to get to the point of Brienne being able to win, her being a better fighter
Gui: They could have played more to that and showed how she has to be smarter
Gui: She has to be more strategic than just also being a brawler, or if they want her to just be a brawler
Gui: Then they should just clash swords
Gui: Somehow they both get disarmed and get right to the point of the nitty-gritty where they're punching and headbutting one another and then show
Gui: Who has the best who, who has the most heart in that aspect
Niko: What I would do is I would make it almost just like a uh
Niko: Like a samurai showdown, where it's like, two dudes stare at each other talk
Niko: Look
Niko: Like they shot their hands up in the swords, the blades shining in the sunlight, the sweat dripping down the chin
Niko: And they yell, they right each other
Niko: "Bling bling bling" and they break apart again, and it's just like two or three hits
Niko: And I wouldn't worry about the choreography at all because clearly the choreography isn't that good
Niko: It would just be entirely about the emotion
Gui: Setting up a fight and doing a fight
Gui: On tel-, for television and doing it for film or you, you have different time with your actors in comparison
Gui: They also have to... they're probably trying to shoot multiple things at the same time
Gui: Because it's shot in so many different places and I wonder if this was a splinter unit trying to get this fight together
Gui: So, I give them some sort of leeway, but they got way too much money and budget for game of thrones to look like this
Ashton: I saw someone die late last night
Have you been taking your medication?
Ashton: You don't get it... she's here
Ashton: She followed me here
You're not in your right state of mind
Ashton: Look
[Fly buzzing]
Niko: Gui catch the fly, catch the fly, it's orbiting you, wait for it
Niko: There it is
[Fly buzzing]
[Blowing]
[Smack]
Oh!
Niko: You did it! you did it, he's right there
[Laughter]
[Clapping]
[Second fly buzzes]
[Laughter]
Niko: Oh my gosh
Niko: Gui, thank you so much for joining us
Niko: Guys follow Gui on instagram, if you have not
Niko: He has some awesome stuff, ask him some questions. Maybe he'll respond
[Smacking]
Clint: What the... ?
Clint: Did you get it?
Christian: I got it
Clint: Oh my god
Niko: Oh sh-
Clint: How many are there? How many are there?